[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
you wesh la météo aujourd'hui c'est de
la boulette allez on se fait la TAF taf
c'est quoi les bails aujourd'hui c'est
un temps de ouf et c'est pas du mytho
les Noirs ça ça passe crème l'après-midi
c'est poser quoi je suis en kiffen grave
ça passe un peu le matin je vous le dis
cage trop tard cette journée je suis
censé
ils ont pris tout le monde de cours
personne ne s'y attendait séparé depuis
le 22 février 2021 les Daft Punk ont
tout simplement cassé internet hier soir
à 22h22 le 22 février 2022 Daft Punk a
ouvert un compte sur Instagram un compte
Twitter et surtout un compte sur twitch
la plateforme et le réseau social
beaucoup d'internautes ont bien cru un
retour des Daft Punk un an jour pour
jour après l'annonce de leur séparation
et puis dans la soirée
un live complet donner à Los Angeles en
1997 à l'époque le duo français n'est
pas encore masqué
1h30 d'un chaud mythique et puis s'en va
ils sont blonds il y en a un des deux
qui est blanc
[Rires]
[Musique]
très proche des nôtres
ce mouvement de la main veut dire viens
en levant les bras ce bébé dit porte-moi
il y a aussi ce geste qui comme chez
nous signifie donne
aujourd'hui libération publique qui
révèle que l'élection du candidat à la
primaire LR serait totalement faussée
certainement pas après
nommé Douglas cette manipulation
comment la définir comment pourrait-on
qualifier cette campagne dans la salle
cette campagne mais c'est une campagne
de merde
c'est exactement le mot que je cherchais
[Musique]
monsieur tonton
d'origine cambodienne people français
qui d'ailleurs fait partie et je crois
de réserve de réserve de réserve
citoyenne vous le voulez empêcher de
voter à la primaire des républicains
c'est ça ce que vous voulez monsieur
skitecte vous avez bien compris
je pense que c'est assez déplacé
d'ailleurs de m'attaquer là-dessus
selon les infos libération
aurait voté pour la primaire des
républicains à Nice si quelqu'un a
inscrit son chien le chien n'a pas pu
voter parce que le chien ne sait pas
lire le numéro de code qui est envoyé
par SMS sur son téléphone portable donc
on peut toujours s'amuser à
inviter des anecdotes de ce genre
oui on l'adore il y en a pas deux comme
lui il a beaucoup de personnalité
[Musique]
sur 500 chef mais voilà c'est dit que il
fallait qu'on se trouve un vrai nom
parce que ils ont des couleurs nous on a
pris un animal voilà parce que un tigre
ça fait tapis dans la forêt ça arrive à
tatillon ça examine et après craque ça
bouffe exactement
quand je suis descendu sur un terrain de
rugby j'ai jamais entendu un entraîneur
veut dire bah écoute va faire un tour va
prendre 40 points à la maison non si tu
as ça tu restes au lit moi je veux
diriger ce pays vous êtes
hyper convaincant
bravo on est en difficulté parfois sur
les réseaux sociaux vous mettez en
difficulté avec ce genre de choses et ça
c'est pas bien de votre part parce qu'on
est parfois ciblé donc franchement ne
dites pas ça parce que d'abord c'est pas
vrai
[Musique]
excusez-moi de parler
la réduction de la tension ça passe par
les interactions sexuelles qui sont là
pour non seulement réduire le stress
mais aussi pour renforcer les liens
faites l'amour pas la guerre on les
surnomme les singes
[Musique]
c'est le Guardian qui rapporte c'est
drôle d'aventure arrivée à Rémi Linol il
est fondeur finlandais alors fondeur
extrêmement fine il faisait moins 20
degrés et par conséquent et bien il a eu
le pénis gelé il a donc décidé de
prendre une bouilloire pour se
réchauffer une petite bouillotte
[Applaudissements]
ah bah oui
c'est l'idiot il a dit que c'était le
moment le plus douloureux alors
rassurez-vous
dans les froid dans les flammes
je suis Arnaud Dion
pourquoi tu mettrais pas le parleur donc
j'ai travaillé j'ai travaillé et de
temps en temps et je j'arrive à faire
rire avec imitation foireuse mais je
progresse